the pedos are being normalized
this is not a crazy conspiracy theory
this is
we've seen this creeping up in recent
years and the libs have always said no
you republicans you're crazy conspiracy
theorists and then you remember there
was that assistant professor at dominion
old dominion
university and that professor came out
and said look we need to stop
stigmatizing pedophilia i don't even use
that term i call them maps minor
attracted persons and then what did the
libs tell us they told us no no maps
minor attracted persons redefining pedos
that that's a that's a joke it's a meme
it's a crazy right-wing conspiracy
theory now we got another one licensed
counselor
and sex therapist who jenna ellis is
reporting works for the pennsylvania
government i haven't seen a ton of news
reports on that but at the very least a
licensed counselor and sex therapist
advocating on video
for the poor oppressed pedos
i'm a licensed professional counselor
and sex therapist in erie pennsylvania
and today i want to talk about minor
attracted persons
and i want to talk about minor attracted
persons because they are
probably the most vilified population of
folks in our culture and
most folks are making incorrect
assumptions about them without actually
knowing much about them and those
assumptions create harm
for an already marginalized population
you may have noticed that i'm using the
term minor attracted persons sometimes
abbreviated to maps
instead of the more commonly used term
pedophile
and i'm doing this because the term
pedophile has moved from being a
diagnostic label to being a judgmental
hurtful insult that we hurl at people
in order to harm them or slander them
i also prefer person first language that
recognizes that any label we might apply
to a person is only part of who they are
this is coming to a psychology
department near you this is coming to a
mainstream media near you this is
we are
we're not 10 years away from this being
the term of art for pedos minor
attractive person we're probably
two years away
if that
they are now earnestly pushing for this
she makes one good point here she says
pedophiles sorry minor attractive
persons are the most vilified people in
society that's true that's true
rightly so obviously for people who
abuse children
but even the people who just have these
desires
and maybe don't act on them they're
vilified too of course of course they
are and she's saying that's wrong it's
wrong for a desire to be vilified it's
wrong for a person to be vilified for a
desire and there's actually even kind of
a half truth in that
which is that some this is a fallen
world sometimes people are born with
certain inclinations that are bad the
inclinations themselves are bad and they
were born with a maybe a predisposition
to that and that it seems sort of unjust
to judge people for a predisposition
that they may not act on that they try
to resist but that nevertheless is kind
of with them
there's a there's
some truth to that okay
but she's wrong to say we shouldn't
judge pedos
not just people who abuse children but
even people who have the desire
because what is at the basis of this is
something that we have totally embraced
as a society it's not just the left
that's embraced it actually a lot of on
the right have embraced it too the idea
that no desire can be wrong
no desire actions can be wrong but no
desire can be intrinsically wrong and
the reason that we have adopted this is
because the libs have completely
inverted the moral order and the right
has abandoned the moral order for a kind
of moral relativism even people on the
right will say well how do we define
what's good your good might be my bad
just they're that way because we can't
engage in any actual moral discussion
you just you do you i'll do me we have
to all leave each other alone and that's
been the kind of consensus on the right
for the past two or three decades and
it's completely incoherent and it allows
the libs which have inverted the moral
order to get away with murder or
pedophilia in this case
desires can be bad because there's good
and there's bad and we through our
reason and through our moral conscience
can know something about what is good
and what is bad
and we in our political order can
can
create policies that discourage what is
bad and encourage what is good and we
can have that clarity and we can define
it and we're not infringing on anybody's
rights pedos don't have rights to to
to the desire for young children
people don't have rights to things that
are not reasonable and not for their
benefit okay and so we we have to be
able to say that i think a lot of people
even on the right don't want to go that
far so they know everyone knows that
it's wrong to be a pedo everyone knows
that it's wrong to sexually desire
children but we're not willing to take
on the premise that allowed that to take
hold in the first place that desire can
be wrong in itself and we have the right
in politics we have the obligation in
politics to enshrine
our vision of good and bad in standards
and say no you don't get to do that the
other thing underlying this confusion
here this woman's bizarre rant is the
idea that desire is not changeable and
this comes from the gay rights movement
in the 90s when they said we're born
this way
there's
sexual desire is really just sexual
orientation it's completely unchangeable
and if you even suggest that we in any
way try to resist our desires that this
would be conversion therapy and that's
evil and that's terrible now of course
they're changing their tune and they're
saying not only is desire mutable but
but even sex itself is mutable that's
why we chop people up and boys can be
girls one day and then they can become
boys again on the next day and that's
totally fine so they've abandoned that
but you're still seeing that premise
around and a lot of people on the right
have imbibed that premise but that's not
true
desires can change maybe not entirely
but anyone who's ever dealt with an
addiction knows this if let's say you're
an alcoholic and you you drink
the more and more you drink the harder
it is to not drink the more intense your
desire for drinking becomes it's true of
drugs it's through food it's true of any
of sex it's sort of anything and you can
the more you engage in vice the more
vicious you become the more you engage
in virtue the easier it is to engage in
virtue that's that's because these
things are habits and habits become
easier the more that you do them and
they become harder to break the more
that you do them that's true on the good
side and that's true on the bad side
that's how desire works
as well and we've been told in our
culture that you should never resist any
of your desires you've been told that
repression is really bad and repression
and suppression of desires can be a very
very good thing but it's if that's not
even the end stage by the way
that's not even the conservative and
christian view of things the
conservative and christian view is that
we have these desires and desires
are properly ordered all toward god that
desire in and of itself is not a bad
thing but because this is a fallen world
sometimes desires get perverted even to
the extreme perversion of pedophilia and
what we have to do
is sublimate those things kind of
reorder them recognize that our desires
sometimes go in the wrong direction and
stop that and resist them going in the
wrong direction and channel them toward
that which is good
and ultimately toward the highest good
who is god that's
that's the way to actually deal with
this and
i fear that conservatives are not
willing to have that conversation
because they're going to have to get
past a lot of the absolute detritus of
the the moral sloganeering the immoral
sloganeering and shallow
idiocy that we've had to deal with in
recent decades that's the only way we're
going to get through this though and
just yelling and screaming about how the
libs are normalizing the pedos and we
need to pull out the wood chippers and
the helicopter rides again that's really
not going to do it because we're not
taking on the fundamental problem which
is beyond the level even of just a
certain policy or a certain definition
in a textbook it goes into a cultural
level and to a moral level and it would
if we could get there it would restore a
normal political order that is much more
traditional in the united states that we
had until just a few decades ago or has
the culture shifted so far that we can't
do that anymore i don't know certainly
hope we can make america great again a
lot of people are longing to make
america great again
will we have the clarity and the courage
to do it
i hope so remains to be seen head on
over to goodranchers.com
knowles and do not skip this ad don't do
it because i got something that's really
good for you
and really good for lots of kids as well
our friends over at good ranchers are on
a mission to donate 100 000 high quality
meals this month to children in need to
help them reach their goal 10 lucky fans
who purchase a box of delicious american
meat from goodranchers.com knowles will
win a 30 minute zoom call experience
with me on september 30th we're calling
it a meet and greet do you get that
right now i just love that phrase so
much the offer is only valid through
august 31st so you got to go to
goodranchers.com
knowles use promo code knowles to save
30 on your box of 100 american meat plus
free shipping and then you'll be entered
to win a 30 minute zoom session with me
which is a meet and greet let's help
these guys reach their goal of 100 000
donated meals this month
meet and greet
i'm so glad you liked that clip you know
thanks to you we hit 1 million
subscribers we're now over a million
subscribers here on youtube i would like
to hit 1 trillion
by hitting 1 trillion that will put me
well on my way to my real goal of
hitting
one quadrillion so please ring the bell
subscribe get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you